este domingo dio inicio a la Cumbre
mundial de clima la cob 27 y es que la
emergencia climática está estrechamente
relacionada con nuestra salud según los
organismos sanitarios la salud debe
estar en el centro de las negociaciones
sobre el cambio climático con ese
preámbulo la bienvenida es para mi
compañera Marina sardiña con toda la
información de salud Buenos días Ángela
efectivamente la crisis climática es una
crisis de salud y así lo dijo el
director de la Organización Mundial de
la Salud que urge poner en el centro de
las conversaciones las afectaciones para
la salud de las personas que se están
incrementando Pues con las altas
temperaturas con los fenómenos
climáticos extremos con la deforestación
y recordemos que afectan malas a las
personas del sur global a las personas
más vulnerables para hablar de esto
tenemos con nosotros a Carlos Eduardo
Pérez médico infectólogo de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia Gracias
por estar con nosotros doctor lo primero
que quería preguntarles la contaminación
del aire mata a 10 millones de personas
cada año
mil personas en la tierra
973 inhalan gases tóxicos o aire nocivo
Cómo está afectando la salud de las
personas está insalubridad del aire y
que otras enfermedades están
relacionadas
sí Marina recordemos que la
contaminación del aire Es el material
particulado afecto a principalmente las
vías respiratorias generando problemas
por ejemplo como alergias
hiperreactividad bronquial Y esto es un
terreno proclive para hacer
a largo plazo fibrosis pulmonar o daños
pulmonar extensos eso es una parte de lo
que produce la contaminación ambiental
además de la contaminación sobre
alimentos y sobre digamos los ambientes
de trabajo y ambientes educativos que
pueden terminar en complicaciones de
salud pulmonar intestinal neurológica
cardíaca de todo tipo
doctor Buenos días le saluda Ángela
Gómez a otra pregunta para usted la OMS
alarma que entre 2030 y 2050 el cambio
climático causará 250.000 muertes
adicionales al año por desnutrición por
malaria por diarrea estrés por calor en
2020 la contaminación ambiental figuró
por primera vez en el certificado de
defunción de una persona en Reino Unido
Por qué las muertes relacionadas a la
contaminación no aparecen en las
autopsias sino que se usa esta etiología
multicausal
pues definitivamente es multi causal
Aunque es decir no podemos decir que sea
por un problema porque se haya aumentado
uno o dos grados en lo que lleve a la
muerte de los individuos qué es lo que
pasa aumentan primero las enfermedades
transmitidas por vectores por ejemplo la
malaria el dengue el zika que son
transmitidas por estos pequeños zancudos
se adaptan mejor a cambios climáticos lo
segundo Es que todas estas tormentas y
tornados traen daño en los sistemas
sanitarios en el agua potable y eso hace
que las enfermedades intestinales tomen
relevancia además de lo que hablamos de
las enfermedades respiratorias
recientemente y
en el contexto de que faltan los
alimentos por la parte deforestación
Pues lleva las muertes por desnutrición
Entonces es todo un complejo que puede
incrementar la mortalidad está en
nosotros poderlo controlar identificar
individualizar para poder intervenir
doctor y las mujeres embarazadas también
son un grupo poblacional que sufren
estos efectos del calentamiento global y
que se ven más afectadas un estudio
señala que cada año mueren unos 6
millones de nacimientos prematuros
debido a la contaminación del aire y
tres millones de bebé nacen con bajo
peso en todo el mundo Cómo podemos
proteger a las personas gestantes de
enfermedades Como por ejemplo el zika
que se está grabando debido precisamente
a la crisis climática
hay enfermedades como transmitidas por
vectores como el zika y el dengue que
afectan principalmente a las mujeres en
el tercer trimestre de embarazo eso es
un hecho cierto y además de eso las
alteraciones nutricionales hemos visto
como grandes regiones del mundo que han
sufrido este impacto en el cambio
climático pues no tienen alimento y eso
puede llevar a los retrasos o precipitar
en las muertes en la maternidad este
este fenómeno por ejemplo se puede
mitigar a verificar si están
desarrollando vacunas para dengue
vacunas para cica y sobre todo el
control del vector es decir que no hayan
estos mosquitos sin embargo este es un
problema que primero hemos identificado
para poder hacer la acción real pero es
un problema que afecta a las mujeres
embarazadas y Por ende a los niños a ese
binomio madre e hijo tan importante en
la humanidad
y en otro tema de doctor como han
cambiado las dinámicas epidemiológicas
en los últimos años nuevos virus
enfermedades causadas por vectores que
se encuentran ahora fuera de sus
ecosistemas y también la resistencia de
las personas a algunos medicamentos
Sí el problema se vuelve muy complejo
por ejemplo cuando hay grandes
retenciones de de humedad por ejemplo La
Represa se ha visto el incremento de
enfermedades transmitidas por vectores
los tormentas los desastres naturales
enfermedades enfermedades transmitidas
por piojos por garrapatas estamos viendo
también como personas que son afectadas
nutricionalmente son más susceptibles la
circulación de virus respiratorios es
decir que estamos en un problema de una
gran complejidad cuando nos hacen el
llamado a que la salud sea el centro el
cambio climático es porque es un hecho
real patente que estamos en los últimos
20 años haciendo lo más visible pero es
inexorable que si no hacemos algo Esto
va a empeorar en un futuro cercano no sé
ni tan Cien años se ni tan solamente dos
o tres décadas para ver que estos
cambios van a afectar nuestra salud
completamente doctor y brevemente
nuestra salud mental También sirve
comprometida con el cambio climático
sobre todo la de los más jóvenes hoy en
día se habla de ansiedad climática
cuéntanos qué es esto y qué podemos
hacer si sentimos que la tenemos que lo
estamos padeciendo
también parte de la información que hay
pero por ejemplo las tormentas lo que
vemos de la lluvias lo que vemos muy
cercano a nosotros de los tornados
Huracanes nos ha llevado un estado de
ansiedad de preocupación de si va a
haber un desastre mayor o si esto puede
conducir un desastre pues prima tenemos
que aprender a reconocer el medio
ambiente segundo que cada uno de
nosotros puede aportar para poder ayudar
Este no es un problema de los gobiernos
esto parte de la actividad individual y
lo tercero ser sensatos con usar la
información trabajar en todos en
conjunto y no delegar que el manejo del
ambiente es de personas sino es de todos
nosotros pues bien muchas gracias soy
doctora usted por sus respuestas Marina
por poner este tema de la Salud Mental
Es sobre la mesa que cada día cobra más
importancia
y ahora pues vamos con nuestro segundo
invitado del día